There's hints about the proper
and improper ways of engaging,
right?
So clearly the improper way to engage is,
I think most clearly delineated in
the Cain and Abel Story and with Kane
exemplifying the inappropriate
way to engage with the world.
And that's to engage with
the world in a bitter,
jealous and resentful manner.
Now,
one of the things that I really liked
about the Cain and Abel Story and that
theme recurs continually with the,
with the duality of the
brothers right there,
there's constant conflict between a
perspective that's essentially like canes
and,
and the,
and the opposite perspective,
which all,
which I'll get to in a minute,
but Keynes sees that the world is a very,
uh,
tragic place and that the rewards are
distributed to unfairly and that there are
people who do better
and people who do worse.
And as a consequence of that,
he becomes bitter and
resentful and curses God.
And then he becomes homicidal.
Fratricidal which is even worse
than he destroys his own ideal.
Then his descendants
basically become genocidal,
something like that.
So that seems to be the
wrong way to go about things,
you know,
unless your goal is to make things worse,
like it's not like it has
a limited number of things,
has nothing to object to.
He's got plenty to object to.
His situation actually is bad.
He's overshadowed terribly by
his brother who everyone loves,
who does it extraordinarily well
and who's good at everything.
And the story is a bit of ambivalent
about the reasons for Keynes failure,
although fair bit of it's
laid at his own feet,
but he's definitely failing.
And so you can understand why he
would have this terrible attitude.
But the problem is all
it does is make it worse.
So it doesn't seem to be one of the
things I've also learned as a psychologist
sort of pondering these sorts of things.
It's often a lot easier to identify what
you shouldn't do then what you should
do.
Like it's,
I think evil is easier
to identify than good.
I think good is trickier,
but evil stands out to some degree.
And then at least you can say,
if you're trying to get as far
away from that as possible,
we could even say just
for practical reasons,
so your life doesn't become hell and
your family life doesn't become hell.
At least you could get as far
away from that as possible,
even if you weren't able to conjure up
what would constitute the good as an Ame,
you could at least avoid
those sorts of pitfalls.
And I do also think that it's pitfalls
like that that really threatened our
society right now.
You know,
that I see a tremendous rise in resentment
fueling almost all of the political
polarization that's taking place and
seems unfortunate given that by and by
large,
everyone on the planet is
richer than they've ever been.
Now that that doesn't
mean there's no disparity.
There's,
but there's always disparity.
Anyways,
Jacob,
of course,
Jacob on Rebecca d Esau
and Jacob ends up with,
with,
uh,
with Isaac's blessing.
And so that's,
that's a moral catastrophe.
And then he has to run because
his brother wants to kill him.
And so that's the fraud
suicidal motif again,
I like that too.
I think that's real,
real,
really realistic.
You know,
one of the things that
Freud noted constantly,
and this is where Freud
really is a genius,
is that the most intense hatreds and
also sometimes the most intense love is
within families.
You know,
and in the Freud Ian
World of psychopathology,
it's all,
it's all inside the family in in fact,
the pathology in the Freud in world is
actually the fact that it's all inside
the family because people who get
tangled up in the Friday and familial
nightmare,
which is roughly eatable in structure,
can only conceptualize the world in
terms of their familial relationships.
They've been so damaged by
the and measurement and the
trauma and the deceit and
the betrayal and the blurred
lines and all of that,
that they just can't expand past
the family and go out in the world.
So the idea that brothers can
be at each other's throats,
I think is,
that's a very powerful idea.
And it's not something that
people like to think about.
So,
so Jacob has to leave and it's
not surprising because I mean,
what he did was pretty reprehensible.
He betrayed his brother.
But nonetheless,
he's the person who dreams of the
ladder that unites having an earth.
And that's a very perverse thing.
You know what?
But one of the things I
think it does is give,
in some sense,
it gives hope to everyone
because it isn't,
you know,
if only the good guys when
we're really in trouble,
right?
Because it's not that
easy to be a good guy.
It's,
it's really not that easy.
And most people are pretty keenly aware
of all the ways that they fall short,
even of their own ideals.
And so if there was no hope
except for the good guys,
almost all of us would be lost.
And so that's one of the things I really
liked and was more surprised about with
the old testament stories,
is that these people are,
have very complex lives and they make
very major moral errors by anyone's
standard.
And yet,
and yet the overall message is still hope.